so what if anything did you notice uh
about any bathroom issues in your bed
before you left for coachella
well
raquel and i were both in in that bed um
with the dogs and i didn't notice
anything but we left them in the bed
while we packed a bag
to go to coachella you know so that
they didn't so that boo particularly
didn't lose control for about or you
know didn't go to the bathroom on the
floor so you'd leave them in bed until
you're ready to take them outside to the
patio which is their designated bathroom
break area
and what if any plans were there how
often did you have house keeping at that
time at your house
um the housekeepers were there every
morning
or they came every day as far as i know
okay
now
we'll get you to coachella but
why did you tell starling jenkins
that you had been involved in a prank
gone wrong objection hearsay leading
i've said why your honor i didn't say
what she said i'll sustain the objection
next question okay um
did you commit any kind of prank
absolutely not absolutely not and and
why
would
that not be something you would do
first of all i don't think that's funny
i don't know what
grown woman does
i i
was not also in a pranking mood i had my
life was
falling apart i was um
at a crossroads in my life that was
really
serious and i had just been attacked on
my 30th birthday
by my violent husband with whom i was
desperately in love
and knew i needed to leave
it was uh not really a jovial time
and i don't think that's funny period
that's disgusting
and what if any uh understanding did you
have
of mr depp coming back to your bedroom
that night or the next morning
objection culture speculation i'm asking
what are understanding what i'll sustain
the objection okay did you
had you had any conversations with mr
depp about him coming back to the house
the next day
no johnny didn't come back to that house
that was my
that was my you know he owned it but
that was my house when when we were
having any sort of problem in fact that
was my house just 90 of the time because
he just didn't
come back
that was not a place that johnny was
going to be in that johnny was in and he
had stormed out on my birthday and as
per
what we did it was he would go and stay
at his west hollywood home and i would
stay at the downtown places
he wasn't going to come back to the
objection calls for speculation
i i think she explained her answer on
that one
just the last part okay thank you